simply delicious and so nutritious would
you like to come and do my dishes hi
welcome back to tasting hi boots
I'm Vanessa today we're gonna be hanging
out at simply delicious and Los Angeles
the dish that we're making today is a
classic seafood chicken gumbo just that
my gun was a little bit different more
unique and it is a blessing to be eight
times champion in the gumbo world you're
gonna use all fresh ingredients
boom
okay so using fresh onions are you
granulated onions okay everybody add
some babies how long do we saute the
vegetables for five or six minutes until
it gets real tender the type of cuisines
that I have here at my restaurant is a
southern-style cooking with a little
infusion of Creole we have like the
gumbo the web oxtail burritos when you
come here to this restaurant it takes
you back home and that's all changes I
add to the Creole a few fish sauce takes
a little bit longer don't want people to
be I'm patient I just wanted to think
outside the box I don't like my food say
oh it tastes like such and such I wanted
my food you're like oh this is amazing I
never had this type of flavor before so
that gets you faint enhances all my
dishes the next step is the chicken
stock no because I have everything I
want to be Dee's Sifu bling should also
use a little cayenne pepper you can use
the pepper Rica rare lady garlic onion a
little chicken stock I have seasonings
have no sodium no MSG no sugar control
your diabetes and high blood pressure
gumbo is a poor man did something that
when people didn't have enough to feed
their families so that you came up with
something they can add into the pot next
step is chicken sausage this doesn't
look like it's been precooked why not so
as you add it to the pilot yields up
horse flavor next is boneless chicken
breast and honest I mean is it important
to put season
on the meets before you put them in the
pot definitely good to always season you
meet so I can marinate you have the
shrimp already season three you know
then we also have the crab legs gumbo in
the heart of my restaurant it's part of
me and everything that I put in a gumbo
is part of me so the thing is when you
taste the gumbo it's a party in your
mouth it's so good
it doesn't matter like oh maybe this
bowl may have shrimp this time it may
have crab this time like it's just like
the fact that you can just play all of
the best meats in one pot and it just
comes out amazing so is this really
going black in the shrimp and then we go
to deep fry the shrimp this is a
homestyle go boom okay but this is not
something that we serve here at the
restaurant all right well I'm gonna get
the real taste I'm just like food to
make something that's real quick simple
and easy and by the time they eat they
don't be like oh I don't like me because
I've been on the stove for hour and a
half so since you do a quick style cook
does it change the flavor at all that's
just the main thing it doesn't change
the flavor at home we're gonna add the
prelector fish sauce I just like to put
a little bottom has a lot of flavor
Wow look at all that is crazy about all
these cheap ones that's true so do we
put any toppings yes we do you ready to
put in the blackened shrimp
yeah no the fried shrimp a little bit
more of this interface sauce gonna add
some of this garnish now it's time for
me to taste this creation of my famous
classic gumbo I'm so excited to try this
gumbo with the blackened shrimp and the
smokiness of that a crispy shrimp
I see the different chicken pieces in
here I want to really see how that if
they really captures that together I
cannot wait to dive into this gumbo off
you later all right okay so I'm about to
dive into this dish I'm so excited
already so I got a little bit of the
fries and
chicken faucet which is great
my chicken is like super tender I'm
tasting a lot of crunchiness from the
shrimp then you get the nice spices from
the blackened trap so I did a and French
means to smother suffocate cover and so
you definitely get that whole component
in this bowl of gumbo because he
smothered the rice and then he smothered
it again so you were definitely getting
a whole feel of a bit too big about I'm
gonna have another bite at midday show
you get the comtab another bite will
complete okay get the shrimp get the
shrimp and I get this okay yeah all
right there's so much flavor
[Music]
[Music]
so thank you so much to chef D for
letting us come in to simply delicious
and try the gumbo and show us how to
make it so that's it for tasting alright
see you next time
[Music]
you